il est 22h30 hier soir quand la salle
d'audience se vide enfin isabelle
fouillot apparaît fatigué comme résigné
après le longue interrogatoire de
johnatan d'aval j'attends des réponses
et puis y'a rien au bout je pense qu'on
en aura pas des réponses johnatan d'aval
on a pourtant donné
recroquevillé dans son box l'accusée a
eu beaucoup de mal à s'exprimer
mais il a franchi une nouvelle étape
importante dans ses aveux gelé saisi par
le cou j'ai serré quand j'ai senti
qu'elle s'affaissait j'ai relâché
quand on étrangle comme ça c'est pour
donner la mort on veut une vérité qui
existent ou qui n'existe pas il n'en a
pas d'autre il reconnaît les faits il a
reconnu il a reconnu si je lis bien
entendu l'intention homicide
qu'est ce qu'on veut de plus on veut la
vérité où on veut une histoire
la journée s'est conclue par l'audition
de nouveaux témoins des amis de johnatan
et alexia qui ont tous reconnu que les
rapports du couple se détériorer un
élément crucial pour la défense
on est maintenant très loin d'une couple
parfait sans histoire il y avait des
tensions il y avait cette obsession de
l'enfant n'avait pas tout a été confirmé
tout ce qu'a dit du latham avec ses mots
à lui cet après midi a été confirmée par
les témoins qui ne sont pas des amis de
dieu nhat hanh qui ne faut pas de son
côté ne le disent pas ce dock qui n'ont
pas là je dire d'eux quand ils sont des
amis du couple étaient des amis du
couple et des amis d'alexia pour les
parties civiles reste la question du
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui a poussé johnattan a tué
alexia les dernières heures du procès
s'annonce déterminante alors que l'on se
dirige vers un verdict dans la journée
de samedi